the jurogan experience what do you think
about the concept of universal basic
income
yeah i you know no i mean i don't think
that's a good idea
but when you have a situation like a
pandemic
where so many people through no fault of
their own are being
forced out of work they cannot work
that's in that temporary situation but
isn't that
a good argument for universal basic
income at least for
a temporary situation well when people
are sick they need to be taken care of
when they're healthy they don't need to
be taken care of they need to stand on
their own two feet
right but when you have a situation
where they can't stand on their own two
feet because they're literally not
allowed to work
like california i mean california
they're they're just they're right now
shutting down restaurants that
serve outside yeah well i mean
the the alternative is not to shut down
the economy
no listen i agree but there's a lot of
people that they get
really hysterical about this and they
think this is the only way we're going
to save people there's a lot of people
out there with
terrible health and they think that
what we need to do is shut everything
down and that's the only way we're going
to be
safe i was reading this woman's twitter
the other day
i just uh someone said something
ridiculous and i'm like oh my god i need
to check this person out
and they were talking about hey you know
i am ready to
lock everything down for five weeks i
don't go outside i stay away from
everybody
i order my my groceries delivered i'm
ready to lock down for five weeks i'm
like
this is the most simplistic and
individual perception of this problem
that
everyone should do what you're capable
of doing
and most people can't do this if they
have a [ __ ] business
like they can't i'm ready to lock down
for five weeks well congratulations to
you
but some guy who runs some whatever
figure out whatever store it is or
whatever kind of business
they need to be there in order to be
open
to stay to stay alive there's no other
way to keep that business alive
they have rent they have overhead they
have they have employees
you know you know the history of the
1918-1919
influenza epidemic that's the worst
pandemic
that we know of in our modern history
and that's only 100 years ago
and
50 million people died worldwide i mean
how many people died worldwide and covet
a couple million at this point
and the population was four times
greater than they didn't shut anything
down back then what do you mean the
population was four times greater than i
know it's four times greater now yeah
than then it was
one 25 it was 1.8 billion people back
100 years ago across the world so you
could scale that up
pretty pretty largely exactly and that
was a killer that didn't just take
people with comorbidities it took
children
it took healthy adults it was
non-discriminatory
disease and we took precautions people
you know social distance and but at the
end of the day
the economy did not shut down humanity
went on with their lives
and this is not nearly the same type of
pandemic that we had back then
it's it's very interesting the time that
we live in the reaction that we're
having today
to covid being so very different than
the reaction we had
to the influence epidemic of 1918 and
1919 which was far more destructive
um it's it's i don't know it's just food
for thought it's very interesting well
what was the difference what's the
difference in the reaction
of today versus the reaction from 1918.
their action
back then was individual responsibility
to
to do what was necessary to protect
yourself and your family
but other than that life went on and
there was no governmental uh um
not nearly the same level of they had
mass mandates though didn't they
if you if you go back and read about it
that not any kind of national type of
mass mandate certain small communities
did it
it was just all so much um smaller
in scale i didn't even know they wore
masks we've been looking at it because
we've been
looking at a lot of photos from yeah
back in the day it's kind of crazy to
see
because they did yeah i mean people were
scared and they wanted to protect
themselves and their family they did
what they thought was necessary
it's just interesting how much different
we're reacting to this one to me and we
are
we are doing great great harm and we
don't see the harm that we're doing
we don't see the small businesses
failing the suicide rates going up the
domestic violence
the isolation the mental or emotional
health problems people have by not being
able to connect with each other not
being able to physically touch
yeah the kids no no they're missing out
in school and in person
that i speaking as as a as a man who was
once a little boy
little boys need to they need to play
they also need to
connect they need they need they can't
just watch a screen
yeah kids i have any they need to be
more interactive
two kids in school right now and it's
soul sucking watching them stare at a
laptop
and then i sat in in my daughter's room
once and watched the teacher teach the
class and jesus christ this lady could
have
not been less motivated it was horrible
to watch
yeah motivating or motivated
they're they're lazy well hope hopefully
these vaccinations
are um are going to be as effective as
their reporting and will not have side
effects in that
that a year from now will be this will
be in the rearview mirror
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love bubba